welcome to new rapid game 2510 Varun
once my opponent so yeah that's Sicilian
again right I'm trying to practice that
oh do we get the Smith more I how we get
this myth morrow against the specialist
it's not so great one let's check those
guys ratings Oh Smith Maura we have
cheese pizza okay yeah good that we have
time to look at those important
information I have played him I've
played him with fifty percent in blitz
in blitz that's weird maybe he had
challenged me once or so okay anyway I'm
taking that poor let's what's what's the
expression pick pick up the gauntlet
something like that taking a volume is
not going to sacrifice it even more
pawns the night a three or something is
really really incorrect
yeah the other question is I really do
deaths of say I have absolutely no
knowledge in this ms Mora accepted when
I got it on the board I usually declined
it and I remember I once actually in
tournament chess took that pawn against
them and player with the bot two
thousand two hundred two thousand one
hundred two hundred something like that
and I got really really crushed so
remember that vividly so especially
after that game are always yeah tend to
not take the pawn but let's just see
what happens I'm playing this line here
with night to g6 night is 796 maybe I
could have played that even now I think
you have to go a six yeah the Smith more
I some not such a terrible opening at
the Sun definitely giving white some
compensation it's probably just about
enough for the pawn so here I was
thinking f6 probably I have to do it
it weakens but otherwise I don't see how
I get to g6 now not just sex ad is it is
some clear that my development is not
brilliant okay that's a luxury oh that's
a difficult word luxurious that the
right pronunciation let's say it's a
peeve really says I have all the time in
the world with Bishop b3 yeah I wonder
what what the right way to play is for
white maybe like maybe 94 and then push
fy5 had this make some sense yeah sorry
so he just aims for p600 it's also
Bishop b6 it's not just Knight b6 Bishop
b6
yo so Luke ph is very very embarrassing
and not a good idea I need some square
for the Queen so maybe castling we
should be 628 that I didn't hear this
move that much but it is definitely a
that definitely not easy for what and
for black I'm sorry with the development
so hampered yeah how do i how do i get
rid of that night down hmm
yeah this is why I rarely took that pond
it's just right if you play it a little
bit just a little bit off as black you
sometimes get into this quite
inconvenient positions just doesn't look
very very fun to play
and we don't see how I am getting
getting untangled here maybe Bishop b4
to a five and then to c7 something
something like that and it looks wrong
sup
ah I have a different idea maybe f5 f5
intending F for cutting off that Bishop
e3 from the night and if he takes it
rook takes for a possible future d5
sorry
yeah that's that's interesting
definitely
25 I mean I I expect him to play
something like Luke see one dude I don't
know if he had something more sorry more
forceful but I don't believe it don't
really see anything great
my rook c1 is very likely do I go at
five then or not he doesn't have any
direct technical stuff I believe
I wonder if you can take it and plan
something like Bishop situ where's my
rook going the night on g6 if we can if
it takes that and I have to take with
the H porn it's a bit too ugly to to
stand i guess i am not totally sold on
that f5 idea sermon has some drawbacks
but i really don't see I don't see how I
untangle really if I'm not doing that
maybe Bishop before a fire but that's
really slow
with hindsight maybe instead of Bishop
e7 if we check this like here it is
super slow but maybe I should have
played b5 am NOT to prevent 9f oh I
don't know and i also am not quite sure
and how to assess this position I mean
it's inconvenient but it's still a pawn
okay it's doing something flashy I did
not really see that this is possible but
the big question is is it good in the
first place so this should be six is one
possibility I have to be aware of the
real problem is he takes eat eggs King
king edge aid and then d6 not d-texas XD
6 and that definitely gives white
tremendous compensation for the pawn
hmm internets an interesting with rather
we need something that happens quite
often of course in Sicilian but they did
to play with these six is pretty good
I really like to take if possible simply
to change this whole this whole arm this
whole structure and get rid of this
piece of skin gain to be six all the
time but takes it takes us really a
problem just a very good compensation
b5 is of course a possibility just
trying to prevent Bishop b6 in that way
okay I can always take or operate with
that idea of taking one in seven and
putting something on c5 yeah come on
let's let's go be five it's not as I
said it's not okay exactly thrilling to
play this but probably have to yeah in
the right hands this some this gambit is
the squad an idea to play really think
so if you get a good feel for the
initiative and we are willing to learn
some lines because it's not it isn't
some what is an offbeat o-line or more
sideline but that doesn't mean
necessarily that you don't have to work
on it yourself yeah some people think
okay I'll play something offbeat and my
opponent will not know it and this is
good yeah I have to do work less that's
not the case yeah if you play an offbeat
line it basically almost all of the time
implies that it's also a little bit
worse than a main line because it would
be a main line if it would be great so
what you actually have to do is you have
to compensate for a lack of quality with
your own work invested and this way you
can yeah play offbeat opening
successfully by simply knowing them
better if you just put yourself into a
tricky situation with a somewhat yeah a
slightly risky line let's aim and you
don't actually know it wet it it simply
doesn't help you you need to have some
some specific knowledge to
really make it work okay what now that's
an interesting question if I take it
with the Queen most natural move I
expect rooks X by roxy one to happen for
Bishop c5 and yeah that's not a great
prospect that this Bishop might land
there knight Knight takes proof yes
still probably still night XG takes I
mean knigu seven takes Knight a5 is
something that I'm glad to have ya come
on let's take him let's take him my
queen takes rook see what I really
didn't see any sensible move if he gets
a special I mean you again is Bishop to
the six in that case here probably as
well now is a huge compensation really
huge compensation
I totally be willing to return a pawn
for getting rid of some of the pressure
funny thing is that if he goes Bishop c5
and I play Knight a5 which was was an
idea then Queen t6 it's really posing or
asking a very very awkward question b6
sorry b8 is hanging and e7 is saying
remove the night it will take evade yeah
that's really really really bad I guess
good sign is that he's taking quite a
bit of time on that Bishop c5 looks very
normal
and some way I'm threatening d 6 cm now
threatening it's a bit a bit much Edward
but yep trying to patch some dark square
holes therefore I think Bishop c5 is
done the natural move the move to play
I don't really see a good reply to be
honest
should be seven
I don't see a move really after Bishop
c5 there's nothing really am
satisfactory
hmm if I go Bishop c5 Bishop e7 26 I
mean it's it's just so awkward yeah
maybe I have to have to do that and hope
I'm surviving this but it doesn't look
good
how long is he taking for that than some
way to see that actually I don't think
it is he's taking an awful lot of time
for that pretty um standard-looking
booth maybe maybe he is not sure if he
if queen to d6 may be a better move that
sets a possibility Mike will be six also
pretty awkward but against let know even
even there I cannot come by day five wow
I'm head of a clock that's good I have
to see the bright side of things but the
position really sucks
yeah I have no have lots of time to
think what to do I still don't still
have not seen in a decent mood after
Queen g6 or Bishop c5
what about that f5 ideas that is that
any good
hmm and it has a point if I somehow can
remove that upon I might have a possible
defense based on the d5 square let's say
queen d6f 5v5 and then i can try to
somehow get something to the five there
are a couple of ideas
I think I probably have to do that you
know what I'm fearing I hope he it isn't
he's not disconnected no he has a
fantastic connection just probably
taking a long time or got irritated by
our distracted as a better word by
something a typical thing that happens
to me as well having to answer phone
call or taking the door something along
these lines yeah maybe f5 I think after
Bishop c5 or 26 he's not threatening to
win immediately it's just just a very
imposing position but there is no direct
loss inside so maybe a five is possible
let's do it very strange can you see
that actually how long is this is taking
eight minutes now on that move it's hard
to believe
maybe Bishop f4 is a move it's an
interesting move I have to move the rock
then then Bishop t6 no also very very
very very logical way of playing yeah
what am i doing with that recording if
it's never playing it let you move 25
minutes down the drain now maybe I'm
going to release it anyway got some
interesting points though even though I
will know is coming up with Queen d6 so
um I was thinking f-fire film but I mean
it's not like I'm trusting that move
yeah come on let's not think for hsm one
important point is that it fights as I
said for the D Phi square in some cases
let's say he goes 'if I've I can try to
get something to defy like Bishop d7 95
then 95 or so and in a in a perfect
world which probably yeah will not
happen
I 595 I'm blundering the rook so not
happening immediately but f5 looks shaky
i have to say but i had simply didn't
see another move a different move
now if I've is probably probably okay
can only of course raise the question if
there's something much better because
well my position looks ugly yeah and
there might be something that directly
tells me I don't see it at the moment
but then there might be something it
wouldn't be very surprising if there's
something drastic available that just
wipes me out 'if i've probably nap you
should be services actually even look
the one
there should be seven rook to d1
I said some way if I get the night to d5
the whole thing is ok but do I get it
down what about a 5am 484 and then 95
maybe that gives me some sort of counter
play one issue is also that that Luke on
be a jazz always under that influence of
the Queen on d6 so maybe it would help
me if I can activate the rook somewhere
on the B how
and it is 10 second increment very
important but 10 second is some mean
this is a good increment that is totally
sufficient form I'm getting totally
winning positions to a win or drawing
the dead positions but it's not like yet
all the time in the world so his clock
is ticking down and I played relatively
quickly maybe a bit bit too quickly
judging from the from the quality of my
position a funky idea would be to get in
something like let's say a 4 B 4 rook b5
something to defy if Heaven would be
nice but probably am difficult to get so
here I wanted to go a foreign before
yeah let's do it and it's not it's not
like I'm playing on time here but
playing a bit quicker make sense given
that I'm that fire head on the clock
putting some pressure on him
this is for example we had we had
situation why is he spending time yes so
before threatening be three now come on
it takes it Andrew takes I'm actually
now using that rook actively
yeah I feel like I'm gaining a little
bit yen
again it's probably not very economical
spending a huge amount of time here
probably you have to take on before but
okay it's not not the greatest time
management person in my games here with
commentary I'm not a I'm not a time
travel guide over the broad chest not at
all but here with the with them live
commentary are quite often get into into
time pressure okay well I would have
liked to take with the night on before
but the route was again hanging and now
the rook has become to life a little bit
and I will take be too so just like that
if it gives me that point I will take it
checking the bleep horn would be very
helpful simply in terms of defense that
in cases where I might lose the a power
now then then I will still be left only
with King side pawns so that would be
quite them quite helpful if I get the
beep on but he can of course just them
um yeah just cover it somehow my book be
one looks very meek so he actually gives
me that pawn is there a problem with
taking it
not sure I seen playing something like
night you fireball something like that
ok it isn't it doesn't really matter I
have to take it
you're it's a huge progress that I've
gotten that porn
she still has quite a big pressure up
don't get me wrong I'm not not
celebrating here being enthusiastic
about my position I'm not but it it was
it was worse before I believe so um I
don't see it particularly I don't see a
threat so what I'm trying to say but he
has this pressure of course
it's hard to improve actually for what I
mean he has a super active position but
is there something that you can do can
do with it you don't really see he
doesn't have a threat maybe 95 something
like that so it's there but the problem
is is rather that I have a hard time of
moving anything it's not g5 threat maybe
it is
hmm mayan igf-i is not really a threat
how do I play this here can I have the
sea Bishop
sure I would love to get this Bishop
into the game but I don't really don't
really see how okay so oops let's go age
6 I wasn't really sure if not g5
threatened but also I don't see a
particularly great move yeah maybe you
can just play that rook c4 and pick up
that a pawn look-see for Bishop c4 and
then pick up the airport
one thing would be interesting but not
it's not working right now is to take on
a to give up the exchange and then put
the knight on d5 for great night square
there but it's not not working at all
due to due to what exactly um be sure
quinta gravid okay 94 that is
interesting threatens night a knight c6
first and foremost if i take d for his
taking e7 i guess
okay but that is not not such a big deal
94 I rather think he will take cake with
the rook or something blah then we
should be sixes huge problem
hmm ok i Henry have to I really have to
think about this now
let's let's start 94 Queenie 727 but
should be 792 check moves Knight c3 this
this must be good for black hair don't
don't don't see that one happening takes
on d4 Bishop de forehead looks that
looks terrible ever wide so he will take
and take with the rook after which
Bishop is six in the threat and also the
noid hangs ok there should be six I can
play 96 after Queen f8 Queen f8 Bishop
aveda still night XD four so he has
bishop is six though I take it
now Bishop is six takes Queenie six
Quincy six wow thats it's plain ugly
really is
there should be six kicks move
yeah but that's not that big deal at the
end maybe I can can can still play that
even though it looks yeah doesn't look
great it's there is there any other
candidate movie actually night x 6 is a
threat maybe maybe rupee eight maybe
just rupee aid
which looks really really ugly jinx I
can do this now okay let's take them is
he plays very hip he played that very
well I'm in more than trouble so rook
takes d4 I wanted to play knight c6
before I do that do I have is there an
alternative no Queen takes haha talk
about neglecting moves I totally totally
did not think about this and he has
Bishop is six strong strong rules
Wow so um where do I go we should take
c6 one good thing is that I'm two pawns
up that's it that's it's quite quite
helpful
huh so take a to rock chicks I don't
have 95 my other look is also hanging
should take some six I tell you they're
very ugly stuff and the traditional
problem is that he will take on d7 as
well
unless I go Ruby 7 which again is
amazingly ugly stuff
but okay come on 24 I've looked a couple
of simple moves there he can simply take
a 6 take a form I mean then that alone
is such as absolutely absolutely
terrible rook takes a for something is
just fantastic for what
and well he probably has battles that
might be one of them so
yeah why do I go here to g6
can just play Bishop t5m something like
that Andrew p8 Bishop of seven is also
great night c60 gladly take on f8
there's some way of letting him take 1
is 7 so that I get one one piece back
afterwards there's some way of doing
that
a queen is 727 Bishop e7 rookie aid and
I will get one Bishop bag the problem is
that you always has been shipped e5 with
the tempo Wow
and here 96 I should have gone to age
seven probably I mean it's it's it's bad
anyway but each seven was better
you
you
I would have no move it's amazing how
bad this is can i play if I take on
these six clean da droop droop THX loses
everything
I have no move him that's quite amazing
I mean amazing but i knew that i meant
big trouble but still went down the
drain really quickly he has stuff like
age six and so probably had to be far
more precise there so 96 Bishop g5 is
there some way of putting getting
counterplay I go to g5 for example and
you would take Bishop take that is going
to play a little bit that's okay it's
probably just lost anyway so don't let's
not be too critical their second guess
everything at least Queen Queen g5 from
might post some sort of practical
problem
maybe I'm now f takes is six becomes an
option to give away an extra still not
know it just too bad okay my ideas
screen g 5y at roger to irritate them
but ok yes a ton of good most Bishop g5
is good rook see one that that I did not
expect if i go to g5 now isn't that a
bit annoying ASL a specialty five
yeah anyway em come on let's do it
Bishop d5 is just good though
yeah keeps that secures the bishop mean
after all I'm not threatening to take it
secures the bishop and cover some
capacity to I cannot play night h 4f
four as FA dis hanging so he has to or I
have to do something else this move ok
but therefore huh for let's let's let's
let's meet the check whoa
okay well I'm just a bit stunned so he
needed a moment to to grasp what he just
did okay so i can now take III there
rook f8 King h7 check on g8 running all
over the place now why just take a 6ft x
is six ok fate king edge seven Bishop f4
why should we now
yeah I think I should win check
so Queen where to age five the all
important thing is that i have the apron
not here for quincy to or look be one
there the right moment
oh yeah he played an excellent game I
was I was just losing rook be one yeah I
think so I don't think he can stop the
airport
yeah there was a very lucky turn of
events it was a really bad position boom
okay three now can push the pawn and
help
okay well I was a lucky game white
resins a very lucky game let's let's
check this probably we will see tons of
possibilities for him yeah around here I
think this is something that's probably
known but I have to go be 5 m that is
really much better not allowing that
afore I wasn't really paying I didn't
really had this on the radio I am 94 but
I have to do this probably not for I
mean very often in the Sicilian b5 is
played to undermine this night and so on
here it's mostly and move to defend
against night a form and here that's
it's already quite blue yeah and I
cannot do this because Bishop be 60 yeah
and now he is getting this this great
compensation that's a funny move 95 the
problem is i said is is that here that
is not taking but playing d6 thats it's
it's the real real issue if he takes it
I'm okay yeah it's equal material oh now
i'm still a pawn up ok sorry i'm also
point up here but anyway this is not the
point white will play d 6 g 6 and then
take this bishop and here i am again
suffering on the dark squares a lot so
b5 is probably better yeah maybe with
hindsight I should have played tag with
taken with the Queen then f5 yeah that
was my lash out move because I didn't
want to sit passively any longer rugby
sevens through the engine suggestion for
Quincy seven now it's damn ugly
white white as a fantastic game he five
if I really felt that around here I was
making some progress push up here I was
even able to take this now aged 6 h-6 is
probably bad a comp gives Queen a five
and then possibly rook be seven things
two pawns but White's compensation is
quite quite remarkable k h6 is probably
not a good idea 94 and now looky aids
yeah I really did not appreciate Queen
takes but probably what I thought also
this good was I was thinking of what was
the line rupee eight or something king
of Salman water I was thinking that this
is actually a move Bishop here and this
but we're k can take here and it's just
better it's just terrible here Bishop
Jake's and queen d6 and white wins oh
yeah great game he played a great game
here and now this move yeah this is kind
of not quite sure what to do Bishop g5
was what I expected and I didn't really
see what you do I mean I wanted to play
this but ok this is actually nice ok he
cannot take this is this is a bad idea
but he can play f4 that's a nice one
suggested by the comp Queen takes Queen
g6 and night eggs check this of course
so no move so Roxy one is still winning
but let's see we should be five wins but
he played this and after f4 I am winning
so you should we should be three
probably his nerves were playing a big
party time time ticking down Bishop
Bishop back it's just good it covers
that's that um sensitive square attacks
a look I'm done he went here and after
FY I'm winning him now this just stuff
hangs e-cigs eggs both both for bishops
are hanging Jack he tried that but it's
not not working t exchange hear hear
those rooks they have no real fight
against the Queen a3 a2 and so on is
happening yeah that was a very lucky win
but it shows that even the most ugliest
positions you still have to really kill
off which he yeah he did not manage to
do so yep lucky lucky in that game
thanks for watching guys